[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم دعا اجتماع رؤساء الجمهوريه
والحكومه والبرلمان والقضاء في العراق يوم
الاحد الى ضروره وحده الخطاب الوطني وحث
الاجتماع الاعلام على لعب ما سماه دورا
مسؤولا يخدم الوحده الوطنيه نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما مدى دقه اتهامات الرئاسات
العراقيه للاعلام بمحاوله التاثير سلبا
على معنويات الجيش وما الذي دعى الى اطلاق
تلك الاتهامات
الان ما طبيعه الدور المسؤول الذي دعت
الرئاسات العراقيه الاعلام الى لعبه وما
امكانيه الاستجابه لهذه الدعوه
[موسيقى]
عقب اجتماع ضم رؤساء الجمهوريه والحكومه
والبرلمان ونوابهم بالاضافه الى رئيس مجلس
القضاء الاعلى في العراق قال بيان رئاسي
ان المجتمعين اتفقوا على دعم حكومه
العبادي في قياده المعركه ضد من سموهم
الارهابيين ووضع خطط لانجاز المصالحه
الوطنيه واضاف البيان ان المجتمعين حيوا
شجاعه وتضحيات القوات المسلحه والحشد
الشعبي
والبشمركة العشائر واكدوا على ضروره تسليح
مقاتلي محافظتي نينو والانبار كما اكد
المجتمعون على اهميه وحده مواقفهم ووحده
ما سموه الخطاب الوطني وحثوا الاعلام على
لعب دور مسؤول يخدم الوحده الوطنيه على حد
قول البيان وحذر الاجتماع مما سماها
دعايات مغرضه لاجهزه اعلاميه ووسائل تواصل
اجتماعي تهدف الى اضعاف الحاله المعنويه
لافراد القوات المسلحه وتحريض المواطنين
على النز
زوح تطرق اجتماع الرئاسات الثلاث او
الاربع في العراق للبحث في العوامل التي
تؤثر على الروح المعنويه للجيش اثار
العديد من التساؤلات بشان الدرجه التي وصل
اليها هذا الامر والجهات التي ترى
الرئاسات انها تسعى عمدا لتحقيق هذا
الهدف رغم الاسلحه الحديثه واله التجييش
والدعايه التي تسندهم والاموال التي
يتلقونها فان جنود الجيش العراقي ومعهم
عناصر الحشد الشعبي بالكاد يتقدمون في
جبهه من الجبهات وان فعلوا فلا يلبث ان
ينسحبوا منها
متقهقرة من تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه فما
الذي تفتقده تلك القوات والميليشيات لعل
الجواب يكمن ضمن ما تطرقت اليه الرئاسات
الثلاث من ان الدعايات التي وصفتها بالمغر
وتروج بعض وسائل الاعلام والتواصل
الاجتماعي تهدف الى اضعاف الحاله النفسيه
لافراد القوات المسلحه يتعلق الامر اذا
بانهيار المعنويات وتردي الحاله النفسيه
للمقاتلين وهو امر بلغ من الخطوره ان كان
على راس اهتمام اجتماع نادر جمع رؤساء
البلاد والحكومه
والبرلمان انهيار المعنويات بما يعنيه من
افتقاد للروح القتاليه ترتبت عليه نتائج
كارثيه على قوات الحكومه والحشد الشعبي
فاضافة خلال الشهور الماضيه بينهم قاده
كبار كان اخرهم قائدا الفرقه الاولى
واللواء
8 في الجيش ويضاف ذلك الى تواتر تقارير عن
هروب ما لا يقل عن 11 الف جندي وشرطي في
الانبار
وحدها يتفاقم الوضع اكثر على نحو لا تنفع
معه نصائح خبراء التوجيه المعنوي ولا
مواعظ المراجع الدينيه التي افتت تكيل
الحشد الشعبي اما الاسباب فمتن اوعه
ومتشابك بينها الفساد الذي ينخر اجهزه
الحكومه فيؤخر او حتى يعرقل وصول الاموال
والقوات والعتاد الى حيث يلزم وفي الوقت
الملائم تضاف الى ذلك حسابات طائفيه
تتنافى مع ما تدعيه الحكومه في بغداد من
ابعاد وطنيه في قراراتها اذ يقتصر التسليح
على ميليشيات الحشد الشعبي وهي ذات لون
طائفي اوحد بينما تتقاعس عن مد العشائر
السنيه باي سلاح وذاك من تداعيات خيارات
الحكم في العراق منذ الاحتلال وهي خيارات
يقول السنه انها تقصيه وتحاربه بذرائع شتى
ولا ادل على ذلك من عدم تطبيق حيدر
العبادي حتى الان حزمه تفاهمات بموجبها
تقلد رئاسه الحكومه ومنها تشك قوات الحرس
الوطني وتسليحها وحل الميليشيات التي لا
يقرها دستور البلاد وخطوات اخرى من شانها
تفكيك الازمه واعاده اللحمه الى الشعب
العراقي لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من بغداد السيد احمد محجوب الجبوري
المستشار الاعلامي لرئيس مجلس النواب
العراقي وهنا في الاستوديو السيد لقاء مكي
الباحث السياسي العراقي مرحبا بك ما
والسؤال للسيد احمد الجبوري سيد احمد
عندما نتهم وسائل الاعلام او عندما تتهم
وسائل الاعلام بلعب دور سلبي مثل هذا فان
هذا الاتهام يمكن ان ينطبق على محاربه
الاسلام ينطبق على دعم الاسلام يعني يمكن
ان
تتهم عندما تحت تحت بند بعض وسائل الاعلام
يمكن ان تقول اي شيء الا ترى ان هذا
الاتهام فضفاض الى حد كبير وكان ينبغي ان
يكون اكثر
تحديدا شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه تحيه لك اخ
الكريم ولضيفك
الاستاذ الكريم هنا اولا لازم لابد ان
نستخدم الاس او المصطلح الصحيح الذي ورد
في بيان اجتماع الرئاسات الثلاث وهو ان
هناك وسائل اعلام وليس وسائل الاعلام بعض
وسائل الاعلام لعبت دورا سلبيا وهنا نتحدث
عن وسائل الاعلام التي تؤمن بالدوله والتي
تؤمن بالحياه المدنيه وليس تلك الوسائل
التي تروج للارهاب ومنها مواقع داعش
الارهابيه والتي ايضا ومن هنا ومن على
قناه الجزيره استغرب ان هناك امكانيات
عالميه دوليه وهذه التهمه موجهه حتى
للجهات الدوليه انها غير قادره على اغلاق
هذه المواقع التي تروج لتنظيم ما يسمى
بالدوله الاسلاميه البيان اتهم وسائل
اعلام محدده لم يذكرها لكن اشار الى انها
تلعب دور سلبيا وتنسا وراء السوشيال ميديا
تنساق وراء وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عندما
يكتب الهواه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ما يشاؤون وما يرغبون تنساق قنوات فضائيه
كبيره جدا وراء هذه هل يمكن ان تساعدنا
وتساعد المشاهدين والمواطن العراقي وتحدد
لنا ما هي تلك وسائل الاعلام
المقصوده يعني اجتماع هيئات الرئاسه لم
يحدد دد هذه القنوات وبالتاكيد هذه
القنوات تعرف نفسها وتعرف كيف تلعب دورا
سلبيا في ايذاء المواطن العراقي وهنا لا
اريد ان اقول ان على وسائل الاعلام ان
تنسق وراء الخطاب الحكومي وان لا تنتقد
الحكومه الحكومه عندها مشاكل كثيره ولديها
تقصير كبير والبرلمان غدا ربما سيستضيف
وزير الدفاع وربما سيكون رئيس الحكومه
ايضا موجودا في البرلمان ليتم التساؤل حول
جرى في موضوع الثرثار يعني معنا في
الاستديو مواطن العراقي والاستاذ لقاء مكي
هل تعرف هذه وسائل الاعلام هذه المقصوده
هل يمكن ان تضرب لنا مثلا وقال انها تعرف
نفسها والله لا استطيع ان احدد يعني اذا
كان البيان لم يحدد وترك الامور عموميه
فلا نستطيع لكن ما يمكن استخلاصه حقيقه من
هذا الكلام الذي اعتقد انه لن يستطيع ان
يحدد حتى البيان لو سئل الذين اصدره ربما
لن
يحددوا اعتقد اقد ان هذا يدل على اشياء
معينه الاولى ان هناك هبوط بالمعنويات لو
لم يكن هناك انهيار بالمعنويات لما تحدثوا
عن المتسبب في انهيار المعنويات وهذا
الانهيار في الحقيقه ليس جديد ربما هذا
الاعتراف به الان بهذا الشكل بعد العمليات
العسكريه الاخيره في في الانبار ربما هو
الجديد لكن هذا الانهيار ليس جديدا و هو
مسؤوليه الحكومات المتعاقبه التي تحولت
الجيش العراقي الى جيش طائفي
يدافع عن رايات طائفيه و وتحديدا حكومه
المالكي التي جعلت الجيش في مواجهه الشعب
وجعلته يهزم في الموصل وتكريت وهذه
مسؤوليه في الواقع انا حينما اشاهد
البرلمان الان ينتقد وزير الدفاع وهو
مسؤول عن ما يجري في الانبار طبعا يجب ان
ينتقد لكنه لم يفعل ذلك مع نور المالكي
الذي اضاع نصف العراق وما زال نائبا لرئيس
الجمهوريه يعني ارتقى بدل ما يعني يحاكم
اصبح نائب لرئيس الجمهوريه على ايه حال
الشيء الاخر
ان الجيش العراقي الذي يتهم الاخرون بانه
بانهم يعني ينتقصون من معنوياته هو في
الواقع رهينه اصبح رهينه للمليشيات الان
الميليشيات اخذت دور الجيش الجيش لا
يستطيع مواجهه المليشيات انا انا اسالك
نعم هل هي حرب عادله في تقديرك التي يشنها
الجيش العراقي وما الميش ميليشيات الحشد
الشعبي وغيرها
ضد تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه كي يستعيدوا
الدوله من بين ايدي هؤلاء هل هي حرب عادله
ام لا من واجب الدوله استعاده الهيبه واجب
الدوله يجب ان يستعيد الهيبه وتسيطر على
كل الارض طيب في مثل هذه المواقف تتوحد
الجبهه الداخليه او يفترض ان تتوحد الجبهه
الداخليه هل هي دعوه ترى انها مبالغه بعض
الشيء عندما يتحدثون عن ان بعض وسائل
الاعلام تمارس دورا سلبيا والله هذا صحيح
لولا ان الحكومه العراقيه نفسها تغاضت او
ربما تسببت
في عقاب جماعي لمدن بكاملها بحجه وجود
داعش سابقا فيها تكريت مثلا دياله بكاملها
حينما تم طرد داعش منها عوقب اهاليها عرقت
بساتينهم قتلوا هجروا ولم يسمح لهم
بالعوده الى ديارهم والسيد الجبوري ورئيس
البرلمان يعرفون ذلك جدا لانهم من دياله
ويعرف ماذا حصل فيها وما زال يحصل سيد
الجبوري هل من الانصاف ان تذكر الحكومات
العراقيه المتتابعه حربا اهليه بمعنى
الكلمه وتشق وحده الصف العراقي وتقلب
الطوائف ضد بعضها ثم تتحدث بعد ان يعني
يحدث او بعد ما حدث ما حدث خلال السنوات
الماضيه تطوى هذه الصفحه بالكليه ثم تبدا
في الحديث عن ضروره تماسك الجبهه الداخليه
وضروره وقوف الجميع صفا واحدا خلف
جيشه هو بالتاكيد لابد من ان ينسجم الجيش
مع الشعب وان يؤمن الشعب ان الجيش يدافع
عنه وهذه قضيه دعا اليها السيد رئيس
البرلمان في ع عده مرات عندما تحدث عن
ضروره التوازن داخل صفوف القوات الامنيه
واشراك جميع المكونات العراقيه وبضمنهم
المكون السني الذي استطاع في عام 2006 ان
يواجه تنظيم القاعده الاب الشرعي لداعش
وان يهزمه في محافظه الانبار وقد تعالت
الاصوات مؤخرا حول ضروره اشراك جميع
العراقيين في الاجهزه الامنيه حتى يشعر
العراقيون جميعا انهم شركاء في الاخطار
وشركاء في الانتصار كذلك وهذه قضيه لا
يختلف عليها اثنان حديثنا يتركز حول
المعنويات التي يجب ان تكون متماسكه من
اجل مواجهه هذا الخطر اللي ما يهدد العراق
بس يهدد الاردن ويهدد قطر ويهدد الامارات
والسعوديه ويهدد الجميع هذا الخطر هو ليس
مقاومه ضد محتل القضيه هي قضيه تنظيم
ا فاشي يريد ان يبيد الحياه المدنيه وان
يغير وجه
الحياه حياه الدوله الى وبتالي يجب
على معالجه المظلوميات التي خلفتها التي
خلفتها سياساته الخاطئه لحكومات سابقه قبل
ان تطالب هؤلاء المظلومين وهؤلاء النازحين
هؤلاء المشردين الذين قتلوا قتل اقاربهم
او ذووهم الم يكن من الاجد معالجه هذه
المظلوميات قبل ان تدعوهم الى توحد خل
الجيش واعلاء الهمه وما الى
ذلك هذا جدا صحيح لابد من رفع المظلوميه
عن جميع مكونات الشعب العراقي حتى يتحد
الجميع مع القياده ومع الجيش ومع الحكومه
العراقيه ويستطيعون مواجهه هذا التنظيم
المتطرف وقلناها عده مرات ونقولها الان
وسنبقى نقولها ان العراق لن يستطيع ان
يواجه تنظيم داعش ما لم ترفع المظلوميات
عن كل الطوائف العراقيه وينصف كل
العراقيين ولا يبقى ضيم على عراقي حتى
يتوحد العراقيون ويعتقدوا انفسهم انهم في
صف الدوله ضد اللا دوله لكن عندما يرغم
الناس او يجبر الناس على عداء الحكومه
والدوله من خلال الظلم الذي يقع عليهم
فاننا بعد ذلك يجب انلا نلوم احد عندما
يغرر به عندما يغرر به ويذهب بالصف الاخر
سيد الجبوري سنواصل هذا النقاش ولكن بعد
فاصل قصير نناقش بعده طبيعه الدور الذي تو
الرئاسات العراقيه من الاعلام لعبه
وامكانيه استجابه الاعلام لطلب الرئاسات
في هذا الصدد نرجو من حضراتكم ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش اتهامات الرئاسات العراقيه اجهزه
الاعلام ووسائل تواصل اجتماعي بمحاوله
اضعاف الروح المعنويه للجيش العراقي واوجه
سؤالي للسيد لقاء مكي الباحث السياسي
العراقي السيد لقاء ضيفنا من بغداد قال ان
هناك او اقرب ان هناك مظلوميه وينبغي ان
تعالج من هم المظلومون من الذي ظلمهم وكيف
نعالج هذه المظلوميه والله في الحقيقه كل
الشعب العراقي مظلوم يعني حتى اذا كان
الحكومه تدعي انها تمثل الشيعه فهي ظلمت
الشيعه قبل السنه في الحقيقه والجيش
العراقي نفسه اللي يتحدثون عنه ظلم من
الحكومات اللي اسستها واللي تعتقد انها
تسلحها وتستخدم ب ما ينفع الشعب اما
مظلوميه السنه فهي ربما تكون اكبر على
اعتبار انهم مورس بحقهم ظلم طائفي واضح
ومباشر واعتقل مئات الالاف من ابنائهم
وقتل وهجر الملايين منهم على ايه حال هذه
مساله في الواقع اصبحت الان يعني عامه
ومعروفه كل الشعب العراقي يتعرض لمظلوم
منذ الاحتلال حتى اليوم لكن فيما يتعلق
بما يدعون الحكومه العراقيه او الرئاسات
الثلاث من حرص على الجيش في الواقع هم لا
يستطيع عون النظر الى الباب المجاوره
لرئيس الجمهوريه نائبه نور المالكي يستخدم
وسائل الاعلام المتاحه له ونوابه للطعن
بحكومه المالكي العبادي تقصد طبعا عفوا
بحكومه العبادي صحيح وبكل المؤسسات او
بمحاولات العبادي لاجراء عمليه ما يسمى
مصالحه او حل سياسي اتفق عليه قبل تشكيل
حكومته هذا النمط من العمل الذي يشبه ما
عمله علي عبد الله صالح في اليمن تماما
وله منشيات تماثل الحوثيين يعني له جناح
مسلح وبدعم ايراني ايضا هذا العمل لحتى
الان لم يستطع الحكومه ولم تستطع الرئاسات
الثلاث تشخيصه او على الاقل الانتباه له
او محاوله منعه لانه اقوى منهم في الواقع
هم لا يمتلكون القدره اليوم الجيش العراقي
مقصوص الجناح الجيش العراقي نور خالد
العبيدي وزير عبد القادر العبيدي وزير
الدفاع اعلن انه بعض ال واحده طلبت اسلحه
وذخيره من الميليشيات لانها لا تمتلكها في
بعض المواقع الميليشيات اصبحت اقوى من
الجيش اليوم الشرطه والجيش لا يستطيعون
اجبار الميليشيات او منعها من القيام باي
عمل في الشارع قتل الناس ذبح اعتقال لهم
اصبحت السلطه موازيه للدوله السيد لقاء
يعني لفت النظر سيد الجبوري الى ان الملك
ربما ترك له اذرع قويه داخل ما يسمى او ما
يمكن ان يطلق عليه الدوله العميقه وم ب ها
بعض وسائل الاعلام او بعض
الكاتبين على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هل
تعتقد ان بيان الرئاسات في العراق كان
يقصد
هؤلاء يعني لا لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ان
المعركه في العراق الان وتحديدا فيما
يتعلق بال الدعايه بروباجندا الدوله واللا
دوله الان هناك صراع بين من يقف بصف داعش
ويريد تغليب على الدوله كسر هيبه الدوله
في العراق وبالتالي الاضرار بالمواطن
العراقي دعني اقول وليس هذا يعني هذا خبر
من على قناه الجزيره في هذه اللحظه الذي
التي اتحدث فيها اليك هناك عده تفجيرات في
مدينه هزه مدينه بغداد قبل لحظات واعتقد
ان هذه التفجيرات ايضا لها مساق ومسار
سياسي ربما يريد استهداف حتى وجود
النازحين في في محافظه بغداد اعتقد ان
العمليات الارهابيه بدات تسوق
على انت قلت في بدايه هذا اللقاء ان بيان
الرئاسات لم يكن يعني هؤلاء المنادين
باللا دوله او
المتمرسين المنادين باللا دوله او
المتمرسين خلف هذه الجماعه او هذا التنظيم
الذي يريد ان يخطف الدوله العراقيه انت
قلت هذا يعني بما يعني ان البيان يعني
اناسا يؤمنون بالدوله من هم
هؤلاء انا اقصد هناك من يؤمن بالدوله ومن
لا يؤمن بالدوله هناك خلافات سياسيه طبعا
اي التعلق بموضوع الحكومه وزعزع وضع
الحكومه هذه قضيه ثانيه لكن المعركه هي
ليست معركه السيد العبادي مع خصوم سياسيين
داخل التحالف الوطني مثل ما تريد توحي اله
الان انا اعتقد ان المعركه اكبر من ذلك
المعركه بينا احنا كعراقيين وبين من يريد
استهداف ارواحنا ويريد تقويه داعش علينا
احنا كعراقيين وينزع ارواحنا من خلال
تغليب هذه القوه التي ربما تكون وهميه في
بعض الاحيان ولذلك اعتقد ان المعركه هي
معركه شرف للاعلام العراقي بغض النظر هل
انا اليوم في هذه اللحظه متفق مع السيد
العبادي لو اخالف السيد العبادي لانه في
هذه اللحظه ان لم اقف مع القوات الامنيه
لمواجهه هذا التنظيم المتطرف بالتالي من
يموت هو ابنائنا العراقيين التفجيرات التي
استهدفت بغداد قبل قليل هي قتل ببساطه
شديده اذا لم تتجاوز اذا لم يتم معالجه
الاثار السلبيه لسياسات السابقه يعني
سيقول بعض المواطنين العراقيين انا ماذا
ساجني عندما كما تقول الحكومه او كما تقول
الدوله تحررني من داعش
ثم يعني تهجروني من هذا المكان او تقتلوني
يعني ما الذي ساجني خليني مع داعش
افضل ه هذا لا مو كلش يعني مثل ما تقول
خليني مع داعش لكن اعتقد ان الحاله الان
في هذه الدوره افضل من الدوره السابقه كان
هناك تشنج بين السلطه التنفيذيه تشريعيه
الان هناك تواصل يعني بين السلطه
التنفيذيه والسلطه التشريعيه وهناك انسجام
الى حد ما نعم لا يوجد هناك رضا كامل
ومطلق عن اداء الحكومه وهناك انتقادات
كبيره تتعلق بالملف الامني وبملف الخدمي
ولكن هذا لا يعني اننا في هذه اللحظه نتن
عن وجود الدوله العراقيه لاننا نقتل هذه
فكره واضحه سيد لقاء هل تحمل السياسات
الحكوميه المواطن العراقي الى التمترس
فعلا وراء اجهزه الدوله المختلفه يعني
البيان تحدث عن ضروره لعب وسائل الاعلام
دورا وطنيا هل سياسات الدوله يعني تساعد
على لعب هذا الدور منذ اسبوع منذ تم يعني
هاجر العديد من او مئات الالاف الحقيقه
حوالي 100000 عراقي من الرمادي الى بغداد
حسب تقديرات الامم المتحده والاعلام
العراقي يتحدث عن وجود مدسوسين بينهم
مدسوسين من بين من تنظيم داعش والحكومه
العراقيه تمنع دخولهم الا بكفيل طبعا ما
في كفيل فب النهايه وقفوا وبقوا على حدود
بغداد يفترشون الارض ويلتحفون السماء هذا
رغم ان في العام 2003 و 2004 حدث العكس
كانت هناك نزو كان هناك نزوح من بغداد الى
هذه المناطق واستقبلوا خير استقبال هكذا
يتحدث اهل الانبار صحيح في دياله وفي
الانبار هذا كلام سليم المهم الان الاعلام
العراقي الذي استع ا اهل الانبار اليوم كل
اهل الانبار يتحدثون في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لماذا
نحن يعني الحكومه العراقيه تكرهنا طيب هذا
العراقي الشاب اللي يشوف ابوه او امه تموت
وهو نازحه على ابواب العاصمه اللي منلع من
دخولها الاخ محجوب يقوللي ما يروح لداعش
لا يروح الاكثر يتحالف مع الشيطان المهم
ياخذ مثاره لانه هو يعرف تماما الاخ محجوب
ماذا يعني ذلك ان يها
العراقي على ابواب عاصمته طيب انتم اسبوع
كامل لم تتمكنوا حتى من تفتيشهم وهذا كلام
في الواقع حصل ولا يستطيعون انكاره
الحكومه العراقيه عبات الاعلام وعب الراي
العام ضدها او لا من حيث تدري او لا تدري
ربما يكون لها معاذير امنيه هذا صحيح لكن
تصرفت بطريقه غير حكيمه وبشكل احدث يعني
منح منح الميليشيات والمتضررين بكلامها
فرصه للتق على اهل للانبار بل وقتل بعضهم
س سيد محجوب اما كان ينبغي بالحكومه
العراقيه ان تعالج السياسات الاعلاميه
للوسائل الدائره في فلكها اولا قبل ان
تدعو
الاخرين بالتاكيد
هناك اشكالات كبيره تتعلق بمنظومه الاعلام
العراقي وهذا يجب ان نعترف به هناك مشاكل
تتعلق بخلافات سياسيه تتعلق بحجب مثلا بعض
القنوات الفضائيه او اعاقتها من العمل
لكن خلينا نعترف ايضا ان هذه الحاله
خفت في الايام الاخيره وهناك توجه طيب
باختصار لو تكرمت هل هل هل على الاعلام
حتى يكون وطنيا ويلعب دورا وطنيا ان يكون
بوقا لسياسات
الحكومه ابدا ابدا على الاعلام العراقي
انلا يكون بوقا للحكومه ولكن عليه ان
ينحاز الى الدوله وينحاز الى المواطن
وينحاز الى الحفاظ على بنيه الدوله لكن
على الاعلام ان يكون رقيبا كما البرلمان
يكون رقيبا على اداء الحكومه وان لا يرحم
الحكومه اذا اخطات بحق المواطن لكن اذا
كان الموضوع يتعلق بوجود الدوله وحياه
المواطن علينا ان ننحاز على اقل تقدير في
هذه المرحله ننحاز الى الدوله وحياه
المواطن
سب امكانيه الاستجابه
لوجه الحكومه ل الاعلام الاعلام لا يصنع
الاحداث الاعلام ينقل الاحداث اذا كانت
الاحداث كلها تشير الى تقصير الحكومه والى
هزائم للجيش بسبب الحكومه الجيش العراقي
بالمناسبه هؤلاء الجنود المساكين اللي
قتلوا
بالثرثرة تمكن من انقاذ واغاثه اهلها لكن
اذا دخل وحرق بيوتهم طبعا سيقول حرقت هذا
كلام الان نحن نتحدث عن صور عن اعلام
اجتماعي وبالتالي لا يمكن اخفاء الحقائق
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك السيد لقاء مكي الباحث
السياسي العراقي كان معنا في الاستوديو
واشكر كذلك ضيفنا من بغداد السيد احمد
محجوب الجبوري المستشار الاعلامي لرئيس
مجلس النواب العراقي بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله تعالى في قراءه جديده في ما
وراء خبر جديد السلام عليكم ورحمه
[موسيقى]
الله